tu en stage ici c'est normal que je te
critique non oui je veux juste que tu
apprennes une chose pour notre stage une
seule tu peux arrêter avec la machine je
veux que tu apprennes à faire un bon
diagnostic
si tu te laisse émouvoir par la
souffrance du patient tout perdre à
distance tu fais un mauvais diagnostic
je t'ai dis ça a été plus fort que moi
si tu veux être un bon médecin tu dois
être le fort côté émotion à l'eau we are
bonsoir
non non
on nous reparle déjà dépassé d'une heure
oui excusez moi je devais à d'accord oui
très bien j'en ai encore pour un quart
d'heure parfait
je me réjouis très bien à tout à l'heure
le code qui sonne une heure après la
fermeture c'est quelqu'un qui se fichent
de notre fatigue c'était peut-être une
urgence si c'était une urgence la
personne aura sonné une deuxième fois
c'est la même chose qu'avec tes émotions
tu dois pas laisser les patientes a posé
une fatigue qui t'empêche de faire un
bon diagnostic